(upbeat chimes)
- The most important thing to know,
if you only know one thing,
is that disaster robots
make the disaster go away faster.
My name is Robin Murphy.
I'm a Professor of Computer
Science and Engineering
at Texas A&M, and I work
with disaster robots.
1995, the Oklahoma City bombing happened.
One of my grad students
went up and helped.
And he came back and said,
"We've gotta do it differently.
"We could have had robots
like are being designed
"to go to Mars to get
into places where people
"and dogs can't go."
When we're talking about
our robots either ground,
aerial, or marine robots,
that can help responders
do things that they
can't do any other way.
And so in 1995,
we all started working
toward disaster robots.
It was 2001 before we actually used one.
(fire burning and crackling)
That was the first use of
ground robots for a disaster.
It's the ability to do things
you couldn't do any other way.
They needed to get more than
18 feet into the rubble.
Robots can go into these places to get
to where there might have been survivors.
If I can see what I need to
see, I can make good decisions
to keep the responders safe.
So this is the part where we
make fun of me for driving.
So notice that right now,
I'm driving heads up.
But really the trick of
a robot is to get out,
get beyond visual line of sight.
Because that's really the point.
Disaster City is one of the
emergency management complexes
that Texas A&M has.
It's designed to test and to
train search and rescue teams
on how to conduct search
and rescue missions.
We've supplied robots for 28 disasters,
earthquakes, Hurricane Harvey.
We assisted with the Fukushima
Daiichi nuclear accident.
When we go, we bring robots
and people that we've tested
and practice with in
our training exercises.
One of the biggest
challenges to doing work
and rescue robotics is not the robotics.
It's the everything else.
(soft chimes)
You're going to a different world.
It's really challenging
to be at a disaster.
There's a physiological and
psychological impact of that.
It really takes quite a toll.
So you have to be really
good at what you're doing.
But my job is so incredibly fulfilling.
It's about the science and the technology,
and the way it could be
used for societal good.
That's a big deal to me.
(electronic beep)